consider the line segment ab and a point
P somewhere in between the end points
here Point p is slightly closer to a
doesn't matter where it lies on the
segment a point will always divide a
segment into two parts in this case the
point P divides the segment AB into two
parts a p and
PB this is called the internal division
of a line segment the point P divides
the segment AB internally into two parts
can a point divide a line externally
from
outside sounds weird but yes it can we
see that in another video let me redraw
the same diagram but this time we look
at a few more details let us assume that
the point P divides the segment AB in
the ratio m is to n
if this segment is drawn on a graph
paper all points will have some
coordinates let's assume that point a
has coordinates X1 comma
y1 X1 is the x coordinate and y1 is the
y-coordinate and assume point B has
coordinates X2 comma
Y2 what we would be really interested in
is the coordinates of Point P given the
coordinates of these two
points let the coordinates of Point P be
X comma y we have the coordinates of
points A and B and we have the ratio in
which the point P divides the line
segment
AB we have to find X comma y using all
the information we have so this is how
the internal division formula goes looks
really complicated at first but an
actual fact is very simple the X x
coordinate of Point p = m multiplied X2
which is the x coordinate of point B + n
multiplied X1 the x coordinate of point
a and we divide this entire thing by the
sum of M and N what we just found out is
the x coordinate of Point P it is this
multiplied by the x coordinate of this
point plus this multiplied by the x
coordinate of this point divided by the
sum of M and
N similarly the y coordinate will equal
m multiplied by Y2 the y coordinate of
this point plus n * y1 the y coordinate
of this point and just as we did for the
x coordinate we divide the whole thing
by the sum of M and N we go cross out
here this multiplied by this plus this
multiplied by this divided by the sum of
M and
N this is called the section formula for
internal Division if you're too bored to
remember the formula don't worry you can
just derive it the derivation is quite
simple I would say and we cover it next
the section formula helps us find the
coordinates of a point on a line
provided we are given this ratio and the
coordinates of the end
points
[Music]